jason sedakis and olivia wilde are going
their separate ways e.t can confirm that
the two ended their engagement
after nine years together and if you're
looking for a juicy story
think again a source tells e.t that the
two ended their relationship
with no drama or scandal they quote
just didn't work as a couple anymore in
fact
jason and olivia still see each other
all the time
they quote adore each other and have
nothing but the utmost respect for one
another
the source adds that their kids are
their number one priority right now
jason and olivia share four-year-old
daughter daisy
and six-year-old son otis i'm just
every day more grateful and realizing
how i've completely won the life lottery
and it's just so clear to me at every
stage of his growth
and my own growth as a mother so it just
makes me realize how lucky i am
the source adds that they quote will
continue to be each other's biggest
supporters
especially when it comes to parenting
their children and
their careers i don't know anything yet
but
the most important thing is that being
engaged is a wonderful beautiful feeling
let's just enjoy it there's my rush the
couple begin
dating in november 2011. jason proposed
the next year
the two have had successful careers even
working together on set for the movie
book smart in 2011 olivia who directed
the movie
praised jason as an actor i loved being
able to just kind of like
set him free because he's one of the
best improvisers in the world and i just
loved that we got him to take this bit
of information we had in the script and
run with it and he gave us
so much i mean we were dying laughing
behind the monitor the whole time
and et spoke to jason about olivia's
next project
don't worry darling the day before the
news of the split
broke olivia her production of don't
worry darling got shut down for a little
bit because of some positive tests so
how is she doing with all this i know
she was
really loving directing this oh she
loves it and she's great in it and it's
like a um
yeah it's not easy it's amazing the to
see
her resilience and and and she just you
know she's just
works her butt off you know she's
editing the stuff they already shot you
know
she's using her time you know and she
has so many other projects in the
in the works that she you know she's
she's uh
kicks ass that way